senator place started this morning's
op-ed by writing quote as I contemplate
the Trump presidency I cannot help but
think of Joseph Welch Welch was an army
lawyer who famously called out Senator
Joseph McCarthy and started his downfall
in 1954 Arizona Senator Jeff Flake joins
us now from Capitol Hill senator good
morning that was 1954 you write this
morning we face just such a time now why
are you comparing President Trump to
Senator Joseph McCarthy well this was a
time when Joseph McCarthy had gone on
for a couple of years and had done a lot
of damage and nobody was willing to
speak up
members of the Senate simply let it go
if there were a few things a few voices
that were raised but until this time
until this hearing when the chief
counsel for the Army Joseph Welch
actually stood up they have no you know
decency sir that that really turned
things around and at that point that was
you know kind of a threshold that I
guess we had to get to and things
changed after that people spoke out and
Joseph McCarthy was not able to do what
he did before what's remarkable about
listening to your speech yesterday and
reading your op-ed is that you're not
just expressing your opinion you seem to
be trying to ignite a movement you write
it is time to take a stand against Trump
if he is dangerous to democracy as you
say
should he be removed from office I don't
think any of those remedies are
justified I really don't high crimes and
misdemeanors people talk about
impeachment on the left I think
something's been introduced I don't
think that's the direction to go nor do
I think the 25th amendment in the
cabinet act is either and that I do
think that members of Congress ought to
speak out when if the president follows
through on some of the policies or some
of the threats he's made with regard to
the First Amendment for
or if he continues to in terms of the
the tweets and just kind of the debasing
statements that he's made and and also
on the foreign stage I think we need to
be incredibly careful about what we're
doing and that's what bob Corker has
expressed concern about senator how long
have you been thinking about this and
was there a final straw for you well I I
spoke out during the campaign and
actually before that how long before
Donald Trump ran you know the birtherism
this ugly conspiracy theory about
president obama that was embraced by too
many and then during the campaign when
the president talked about Mexican
immigrants in ways that were done
becoming talking about my colleague John
McCain now he couldn't be respected
because he was captured senator two
points one some skeptics will say it was
easier to do this when you're facing a
very very uphill campaign and likely to
lose number one and you should speak to
that secondly you seem to be saying to
your fellow Republicans if you do not
speak out now this is so serious that
you are complicit in the actions of the
president well I do think that the
longer we go the more this behavior is
normalized and and that that is a
problem
we can't allow our dialogue to continue
to Corson
and so I think the longer we wait the
more likely that that is and already I
think we're seeing the effects of this
new era so if you don't speak out and
listen in the crime or what haven't you
define with the president I think well I
think that we have a responsibility as
elected officials to speak out when
there's behavior that is just beyond the
pale and then some of what we've seen I
think fits in that category you think
you can change the president you know I
think all of us have been waiting for
nine months for that pivot that was
going to occur toward more appropriate
behavior and stability we haven't seen
it I think it's time that we you know
that we stand up and be a little more
forceful how many Republicans fellow
Republicans have said privately what you
were saying publicly how obviously I
talked to some of my colleagues who
haven't been as vocal but I don't want
to speak for them I know there is
concern I think you will in the future
see a lot more people stand up senator
flake thank you for joining us thank you